I have been watching The Handmaid's Tale
on Hulu and it's making me feel some
type of way there's a lot of rape or
something it's not really rape as much
as okay so like basically climate change
overpopulation and a lot of different
things have have caused women to be
infertile and a lot of men to be
infertile as well so what they do is
basically they they kidnap or they
arrest all the known fertile women yeah
and they turned them into handmaids to
basically have sex and procreate with
the higher-ups in government so it's and
then they they make the women wear these
like almost like Puritan like Quaker
little what about if I was a if I was a
farmer I was a guy yeah and I was
fertile also what do you mean no but you
can't why not okay so it gets a little
bit more complex once you watch more
episodes because there are instances of
that but they say this term in the show
called under his eye they say that's how
they greet each other under his eye
because there's always someone watching
the eye is always watching you cannot
have sex with any but for pleasure you
can't have sex for pleasure like at all
yeah you only have sex for procreation
what if I just okay I'm a farmer yeah
can I ask these questions yeah and I run
into it you you're a handmaiden yeah
would I know you from their past life or
now yes you could I could yeah yeah okay
and if we get caught by an eye we're
dead but would you but they wouldn't
kill when you love me though I might for
sure because they're not gonna kill me
because they need my vagina and my
ovaries and my uterus right but they'll
they're gonna kill you but they're gonna
cut off an arm because I got procreate
I'll wear that with it cuz I jerk off
I'll just rip off because like step
outta line they'll gouge and I and
they're like oh we don't know anyway
show me a titty and I go behind a tree
and a jerk-off yeah you can't do that I
can't do that either
Oh we'd get killed
watching but what we could do i doesn't
let people jerk off no it's a dangerous
sorry good do is we could in this world
canada's is a safe place we made love
last week we didn't kiss any we we don't
kiss anymore we just [ __ ] like rabbits
is that normal do you ever look at me
you turn away you look away from him
that's what you'll do this like she'll
tuck her like your neck fat neck and
then like she'll look away from me like
no because I'm much taller so if I'm on
top he's okay if I'm on top straddling
ghost I he's so short so if I'm like on
top but kind of falling this right here
this is her head so this is my hand at
the back of her head you guys you have
to work out yeah I'm working out I'm
five eight right the best do you I have
a question do you guys still make out
like spontaneously no no ducks in the
lips oh yeah we kiss a lot but we just
don't know more [ __ ] it okay how
important is making out because now I
feel like maybe I'm missing out on
did you guys shut up shut up make out
right where's that what I'm making out
often did you make well with a [ __ ]
car I can't remember the last time we
made out during sex all right without
sex
we don't want make out all right Gilders
your love life like i'm gonna talk about
that from friends we make out that's it
you make out they make out a lot baby no
no my mom's listening yeah
you okay with you having snow no or
kissing we're just friends
[Music]